In this episode, I just wanted to walk you through a very simply spread and
slippage, pretty much just want to kind of help you understand spread and slipp
age.
Obviously, again, most of you probably already know about spread and slippage,
but I'm going to give it to you in a way that maybe you didn't actually know
about it before,
kind of give you the overview of market makers and how market makers operate,
which again, you probably didn't know, understanding spread widening and things
like that.
Let's very simply start with spread.
So spread is pretty much the difference between the bid and ask price.
So anytime you open up your trading pool or be a meta trader or a sea trader or
whatever broker or whatever you're trading with, your trading portfolio,
you'll be quoted and you'll get quoted a bid and an ask.
And your bid and your ask is what you're being quoted as,
this is where you can buy from and this is where you can sell from, right?
The larger the gap between your bid and your ask,
meaning you go to execute on a position and it will get filled
at either the bid or the ask and that bid or ask will be different to the
current price.
So for example, if you open up, let's just for simple terms, open up meta
trader on the mobile
and I kind of open it up and go to one minute timeframe, you'll always see two
lines
and one is bid and one is ask and you'll notice that they are different.
You want to buy euro dollar at this point, for example,
you won't get filled unless you have zero spread, which you probably don't.
And if you do, you should be looking at what you're paying in fees because that
won't be good.
But you're not going to be getting filled at that exact price point.
You're going to be getting filled a little bit higher or a little bit lower
than you want to depending on whether you're buying or selling as well, of
course.
And that little difference between the actual price and the quoted price
is called your spread and spread exists so that there is an incentive for a
market maker.
The job of a market maker is to provide liquidity at all points in price.
So if you look at price now, right, there's buyers and sellers coming in
and not all of the time is there an active trader willing to take the other
side of that trader,
that specific price point with that amount of lots.
That's what we'll get into in a minute when we talk about slippage.
But to make the market more efficient and to operate better, we have market
makers.
A market maker is someone who is willing to take the other side of your
position.
If there's nobody else there to provide that liquidity.
So let's say for simple, simple terms,
you want to buy 10 lots of euro dollar at this specific price point.
But there were no sellers for euro dollar 10 lots anywhere below this price in
here.
You want to buy here for 10 lots, but the next available block of liquidity
from
a normal trader or something is all the way up here.
Well, that's where a market maker comes in.
A market maker will make a market.
And so he will be like, I'll take that off you.
But I'll take it off you at this price.
And he will net the difference in what it actually could have been versus what
it was.
And then he'll quickly try to match that sell with someone else.
And so he's making the market.
I know that that explanation explains it really well.
But their goal is to net the difference between the bid and the ask.
And they do that by providing liquidity.
So they're trying to take on everybody's orders and then sell everybody's
orders at the same time.
And they do this now algorithmically with very smart intelligence engines.
But essentially what they're trying to do is provide liquidity for everyone.
And then they have risk departments, which manage risk to make sure that they
are
essentially making a profit when they buy and sell to everyone.
Because they're buying it for cheaper than what it's actually worth.
That's what the spread is.
And so that's how they operate.
And that's a good thing.
Spread is a good thing because it actually provides a market maker.
Very simply, but spread is a little bit that gets added on between where you
want to buy
and where you actually get filled on your position.
And on the sell side where you actually wanted to sell and where you get filled
on your position.
Now sometimes spread can actually work in your favor.
And sometimes it might not work in your favor.
It literally all depends on the context of the scenarios.
I've had time where because of spread, I have been saved from being taken out
of a
position, for example, or got into a position that technically would have left
without me.
And then there's obviously other times where spread doesn't really help.
But regardless, spread operates in the exact same way all the time.
It's pretty much just an add-on fee.
And that market maker is rewarded for making the market with that extra
differentiation.
And it wants to pair all of those transactions as quick as possible.
So they can buy off you right now and then sell that exact same order to
someone at the
exact same price point, but it nets off both of you a little bit of spread.
That's how a market maker makes their money, which is why there was a spread.
Some brokers are different.
Some brokers have larger spreads.
Some brokers have smaller spreads.
Typically what you'll find is a broker that has a lot of liquidity will be able
to have
smaller spreads because it makes sense for that market maker to want to operate
in that market.
It's just supply and demand, right?
So the market maker would be fine with having so much liquidity so that you can
buy and sell
all of the positions and make very small amounts of profit, but many, many,
many, many times,
as opposed to if you have a broker with a lot lower liquidity, therefore they
usually have higher
spreads, it's going to be off the basis of they make more money, but less
frequently, right?
That's typically how it works.
Bread is essentially the difference in the present price of the quote of the
bid and the ask.
And then you have slippage.
A slippage occurs essentially where you don't get triggered at the price you
want it to get
triggered. So if you have a position open to you want to go short in this area,
you could incur
slippage by not getting filled at the price that you wanted, or on the other
end of the spectrum,
you could get taken out at a higher price than what you wanted.
So slippage occurs where you wanted to execute a short position here, you
wanted to take your
profit here, and you wanted to close your position at a loss if it hit this
level.
Well, what can happen is slippage is the difference between where you wanted to
get
in and where you actually got in.
That's the slippage, right?
Pretty selfish, I'm sorry.
So let's say you get into a position and price comes up into this level, and
now price hits your
stop loss. But all of a sudden, let's say it's a news event, and what happens
is the market makers,
they will have liquidity at all of these price points ready to buy and sell or
all price levels.
But what they can do is when there's something like an NFP or a CPI or
something big like that,
they actually have the right to remove all of their orders from the market.
Now, what that does is that cleans out the order book, which essentially then
means there's
a lot less liquidity in the market, which means you may not get filled in this
position.
Now, that doesn't mean that there isn't someone at that price level who is
willing to sell that
position to you for you to buy out of this position.
It just may mean that you are at the back of the queue.
There is a ranking system most brokers typically operate with a kind of like
first
converse of mentality of stacking in the order book.
So if there's, for example, we want to buy out of this position, and these are
the people that
are selling, right? But let's say there was only one person who was available
at this price point,
whoever tried to sell first, so that could be, for example, if you have a stop
loss in place,
that is actually a passive order, you may get outdone by an active trader at
that price point,
because they're willing to pay the difference in the spread.
Maybe they get ahead of you, or maybe someone who put their order in at this
specific price
point before you get filled in.
Let's say there's 50 lots of liquidity available at this price point.
You want to buy 50 lots at this price point to get you out of this short
position.
But let's say Harry set an order at the exact same price point three seconds
before you,
or it got to the servers three seconds before you have that same 50.
When price hits that level and that 50 is available, Harry gets that 50 and not
you.
And then what might happen to you is that you might now need to go to the next
available block
of liquidity, you get triggered out in there.
And so people increase the price with, we go to the next block of passive
liquidity,
where your order may then get triggered at that specific price point.
And you would experience that as slippage, wanting to get out of your position
here,
but you actually got filled here.
And that difference is what we refer to as slippage.
Now here's the thing, slippage occurs.
Typically you might get it more often than not in news events when market
makers
pull out their orders from the order book and the order book gets a lot thinner
,
which means it's a lot harder to fill orders.
A lot of slippage happens then spread widening happens then.
And spread widening can also give you slippage.
You know, for example, you wanted to get in here,
but the spread was a lot higher because of less available liquidity spreads
open.
And actually you wanted to get out of here,
but you actually get taken out at this level.
You would experience slippage.
You tried to fill your order here and your order got filled here
because of high spreads, right, spread widening.
That right there would give you slippage, right?
Again, hypothetical scenario.
So you usually get slippage and it could be on buy side as well.
It's completely contextual to buy side or sell side,
depending on whether in what direction you get your slippage.
In a nutshell, your spread is the differential quote between bid and ask.
And it's usually there as a profit-making tool for market makers,
which is a good thing for us because it provides liquidity at prices
where there may not have been liquidity or we may not have got filled.
So they give us ease of access to fill our orders.
That's the problem they sell for us.
And in return, we pay a premium and they net the difference.
That is why market maker does.
And that is why you see spreads.
Spreads widen when either market makers step out of the market
because the risk parameter doesn't make sense to try to fill orders
when you've got an NFP coming where you're expecting prices to shoot in both
ways,
that they will lose money because they have to match sellers and buyers.
Their whole purpose is of making a market is matching the buyers and sellers
at the best possible prices.
What he wants to do is he wants to buy all the orders from me right now
and sell them to someone else at the same price point so he can net the
difference.
The more orders they have or the more lots they have on one side of the market
that they're not able to sell at a better price, for example, they also lose
money.
So they want to create the best market environment
because they are rewarded most in the best market environment.
Sometimes they will remove their intention to buy or sell at any one price
point
because of something like an NFP or something like a CPI,
or maybe an interest rate decision or whatever it may be.
They have the full right to remove their orders from the order book.
And in those times, you see a lot of slippage and you see a lot of spread wide
name.
Slippage is essentially the difference between where you would have liked
to have triggered a position versus where the position was triggered.
And that will occur because of lack of liquidity.
Spread widening, which also occurs because of lack of liquidity,
or your liquidity wasn't filled at that specific price point,
which is also really just comes out to lack of liquidity.
So lack of liquidity is really the answer as to why you get slippage and why
spreads larger.
There is other scenarios as well where you could get slippage
because an active person wrenched the market, for example,
not allowing you to get out of your position or buy or sell out of your
position.
Other scenarios, but it all does come down to a lack of liquidity
on at least one side, so an imbalanced market,
which is why their goal is to always create an efficient market,
because an efficient market condition,
that is when they essentially make their most money.
Hopefully that explains it.
I know I kind of side tracked and kind of waffled on,
spread, slippage, and pretty much be aware of market conditions when you have
high impact news events or bank holidays.
Expect that those are the days that you will get slipped or you will get high
spreads.
And what does that mean as well, by the way?
Because this is why it can really affect you.
If you're a trader who trades, you know, liquidity hunter SMC or for example,
and your average stop size is, you know, let's just say for maths like eight p
ips,
but now all of a sudden spread is two pips.
And so you essentially end up adding an extra layer of risk.
You get slipped out of your position by two pips and you have only an eight-pip
stop.
You have just added an extra 25% of risk onto position.
So if you had a 100k account, you're risking 1%, and you had an eight-pip stop,
and then you got slipped.
Your stop loss got slipped by two pips, which can happen.
Then you will actually end up taking a $1250 loss.
Instead of 1%, you'll take a 1.25%.
That's why it's important, especially if you're trading small stop losses,
is a big reason why to avoid news events unless it really makes sense,
which I've already covered in a little bit of context.
It's not just about your stop loss, even like you can get triggered into a
position
with an unfavorable feel because of slippage or because of spread.
That is pretty much understanding slippage and spread.
The reason I wanted to create this is because you obviously already understand
slippage.
Probably already understand spread, obviously, but maybe you didn't understand
what creates high spreads, what creates high slippage,
and the role of the market maker in that process.
Hopefully that helps, and any questions, do let me know.
Catch you in the next one.